how long have you been doing YouTube I'm
doing it eight years as of the August
this year 2012 yeah but I've only made
200 videos I think so far so yeah I mean
I make far less videos than like you
guys right so I have to make every video
really count for something that's to be
that video I I think a lot of people
would say that they are I mean I know a
lot of people who really speak really
highly of your content say like sense
but I going on off that do you feel like
the neat like the quality Bob raises
each year with like content that's been
made in Japan like the kind of vlog
stuff or do you feel like you already on
top of that yeah I mean I remember about
four years in there was a channel that
popped up called only in Japan run by
John dog guy and he raised the bar like
I used to just be a vlog kind of yeah
yeah had TV productions like [ __ ] that's
the future that's all your raise my bar
to try and reach that kind of level of
quality and I've noticed since then a
lot of channels also started slowly like
creeping up as well with this era kind
of well say it's production value isn't
as important as people think it is the
main thing is is having content that
people want to watch like I've made lots
of videos out about traveling to
interesting places but the videos always
do the best it's just me sitting in a
room giving a commentary on some I mean
that's nothing at the end of the day
right it's like it doesn't matter how
good of a camera you have how good of a
mic up how good your reading is if you
have a personality of a brick wall no
one's gonna [ __ ] watch you yeah I
mean that's YouTube really right if you
want to get a sterilised document of a
play [ __ ] documentary become watch
something else but I mean that's even
like Louis Theroux right you watch him
as well Marylou he's the host and he he
doesn't like jaws dropped
doesn't judge right he's in the way of
the documentary but he gets just enough
personality well like you want it to be
his documentary you know like you wish
you watch sometimes you watch a
documentary like man I wish Luther I
made this you know it could be and like
I feel like you like almost got a really
good balance with that like I feel like
you interject your personality just
enough where it's like it's really
cements that like I really wish abroad
in Japan cup of this you know what I
mean you know with a good video should
be entertaining and educational there's
a fine line to balance
and that's the most important thing I
always try and focus on and that's what
I found really interesting when I joined
you for journey across Japan right
because you brought up the whole thing
of such quality content to a bicycle
when you when you said when you told me
before the whole thing started they're
like yeah I'm gonna try and release a
video every day and I thought back to
your production quality I'm like good
[ __ ] water when I found out that you
were editing your own videos for that I
was like is this guy insane work time
Joey met me one week who's editing those
videos and cycling cyclocross Japan for
like two months and yeah I was cycling
filming and editing it all at the same
time because I'm a real control idiot
even though I had like two people who
are willing to edit with me on the
journey in the car I remember after the
first day i sat with you in your hotel
room as you were like starting to edit
on me and I'm just like you're gonna
like be able to get I think you stayed
up to like we have to get up I think the
next day and then I go 9 8 or 9 a.m. I
was really really early and [ __ ]
Chris had stayed up to like 5 a.m. what
the [ __ ] maybe like 4 hours sleep at
most like he's like alright guys about
to do a 15-kilometer cycle now how many
times did you do that on the trip yeah
most of the videos came out every day
there's every two days every four by the
end as I once a month I think you would
burn yourself that sounds like an
absolute like fast track to be left I
was much [ __ ]
yeah I saw like the rapid decline like a
mental health yeah broke my heart is
when you did you put it with ammo that
you recorded to travel and record a
video with her that you like came along
for three days and we fill the Ohio
Laker as I oh hi
but Matt's point I've been cycling two
months oh you want to explain what
you're in Japan is just in case someone
Japan cyclocross Japan from Yamagata
Takashi Shimura about 2000 kilometers
the idea was to
film every single day and make a video
and show people bits of Japan you don't
normally see by the time Emma joined he
was the last guest in Kyushu are dead
yeah now and is awful it's a real shame
about that had to apologize to every
yesterday when I met my bro cause I can
only imagine like you'd have must have
been on your end of your end of the road
right and like just having like batched
unusable footage which is at the end the
day it was a it was mostly a success we
had 28 episodes by the end the videos
with Joey
it was interesting cuz in the second
half the journey we went through like
Kyoto Osaka yeah
Hiroshima and then Jerry when he joined
was like nothing was literally Joshua we
feel like at the biggest nuclear power
plant in the world yeah and there was
nothing so we had to improvise and make
like commercials about energy jelly
what's going on here the idea of taking
a place where there's nothing really
going on right I'm trying to infuse some
sort of creative component it was it was
like a creative challenge because we had
challenges every day top of everything
else so I had challenges every day and
the first and Joey joined and the
challenge was make a commercial in a day
for hours yeah nothing here we have to
be really creative we find a train
station where there's a real train
carriage you can go and that was surely
by chance
I'm so lost so lucky he has no idea that
this station had just a [ __ ] empty
train carriage like as a thing it was
right perfect and then the the the
challenge we had to be about energy
jelly right so we had we already had
that that was the only thing we had to
go on yeah we just somehow pulled it off
in a day so my favorite video from the
trip